[Music]
i feel like this is a theory
you guys probably like there's like
people that tell you how you feel about
something before they say
um hey you'll like this like we'll
decide after yeah
but is that a lot of the people that
didn't grow up
a lot of the people that set the rules
of new york ethnic
non-identification grew up
subconsciously in their mind
they want everybody to be the same so
that they can recreate the bland
suburban
strip mall that they grew up in right so
they're subconsciously doing it so
they're like no
we want everybody the same because
that's how we grew up so that means
that's good right right
instead of going i left there for a
reason that's interesting i never
thought about it that way
they probably have no choice now you're
saying it's like a subconscious thing
because that's
how that's what they know that's how
they're conditioned yeah so they think
they're being
they're actually being ten times more
racist than anyone could ever be right
by not identifying people's
uh you know i always just say celebrate
diversity don't point out people are
different you know right right and
so they're you know what they mean it's
just so obvious to me that there's
something
off with it you know yeah park slope is
european all right [ __ ]
my brother's no i'm saying
is european i like that it's hilarious
that's top level yeah
yeah because that's my brother said they
have the kids in the class
they're from france they moved in and
we're back after a year they stay
like all his his daughter's friends
right in like sixth grade
i mean with seven eight-year-old kids
first grade whatever it is
um very advanced and um yeah they're all
from like
different countries yeah spain france
yeah hey what are we losing yeah no
that's just reading about the training
guys i mean the guy is like no just
reading i'm just way too comfortable
with you i was just listening to it
i'm in the middle of trying to describe
my brother's poor kid yeah trying to go
to school her friends leave after a year
and yeah his pants is reading wikipedia
i mean he's reading it off the couch
on instagram you've been sober for how
many years now i don't talk about that
oh sorry yeah
i mean yeah a long time oh a long time
what does that have to do with it well i
don't know because you name it all the
bars but you don't drink
i know but this was back when i was
young oh and your bars don't exist
anymore yeah i remember we went into
that bar in dublin
the cheese sandwiches and you said to me
you said you were like you're like hey
let's go and i was like all right we go
and then you're like if i would have
stayed in there another five minutes i
would have been dead in six months
because it was bringing back memories
because you said it looked like a barn
park slope
you know it's so true yeah the only time
i mean i could drink in
1983. wow i was born in 84. say there we
go
yeah but i'm telling you i i bartended
when i first got
i mean i've been in a hundred million
bars yeah the only time i felt that that
feeling
it was almost genetics was in that ball
with him remember
in dublin yeah we walked in and i was
like oh because they cheese sandwiches
just plain cheese sandwiches
there was a rug like everybody's hanging
out
and those irish guys look like they're
like ira guys
yeah they were just sitting down with
[ __ ] uh you know like the park slope
yeah
yeah and you two used to go there and
drink there bono because there were
irish bars and parks
there was some old irish bars there was
some italian bars and then it was just
kid bars and then it was hippie bars and
then it was like
cujin bars you know guido none of those
bars serve brunch like they do now no
no but mooney's had a salad bar i
remember that i used to hit that stop my
pe
we used to go eat dinner at moonies
really and there was a salad bar but
it's all gone now what is this
lemon store now what is it now mooney's
is like uh italian pizza place now
wow yeah yeah you see i i'm not familiar
with that park slope at all yeah well
i wish i was park sleep it's fascinating
because
of what khan says it was so diverse
around the time i grew up
it must be at some point like in the
like 80s or 90s it must have been like
one of the most
diverse neighborhoods in the world and
even and also socioeconomically diverse
yes
which is like unique yeah because you go
one block that way
you were in a totally different socio
and economic brag when i was growing up
it was like sixth avenue was the cut-off
line right
you went down six oh you went down to
fifth and you were like what are you
doing i mean and now
fifth is the hottest box hope now
seventh avenue is deserted yeah
there's nobody even on the weekends yeah
there's nobody on the street fifth
avenue seventh heaven was hopping
yeah and fifth avenue was hopping yeah
yeah it used to be the absolute reverse
like 7th avenue was like
and then it changed because when i was a
kid like on my block we had the
we had the uh mccormicks the horns i
mean it was all retired irish cops
gargano's italians i mean kid everyone
was sitting out on lawn chairs
we used to play snoop ball and uh and
yeah and like ma
and then like and then like the i think
they were like park slope was like the
first gentrified neighborhood by
people who grew up by people my parents
who grew up in new york and like other
areas
did something well or were ultra liberal
hippies and then moved to park slope
yeah and they were like the progress
they were like the first like woke kids
right
like those parents were like the foes
like hey that's right you know and then
like so they were mixed in with sort of
like the irish working class
i was gonna say but what about like the
old school cops even they were like more
liberal woe cops well i was young when
they but they were kind of like that was
towards the end of that right
yes but even everybody was more not so
much
if you it wasn't it was just everybody
was so mixed in
right that it was like a lot of people
like all the italian guys like
carol street and all those guys they
were like serious people
right but they would talk to black and
puerto rican like there was sort of a
mix
even though it was you know things could
happen and everybody would know
exactly where they stood right but it
was still people right
conversed or people would play ball
together there was just a very
there was very fluid light there was you
know avenues and houses
live next door to each other so it
wasn't like a it wasn't a very
segregated area yeah no it wasn't
segregated you saw each other you kind
of intermingled on basketball courts on
corn people knew each other
yeah it was so you're you think you're
like you know smart and well-spoken and
well-read now because of park slope both
of you guys
yes because in my neighborhood in
ridgewood i mean patty fly balls the kid
just you know
he doesn't we don't think like that no i
think he park slope has a lot to do with
it yeah
yeah so much at such an early age and
like yeah that would
the people who moved to park slope that
was in the air that was the energy it
was intellectual yes
kind of like yeah yes yeah progressive
thinkers
the saint patrick's day parade in park
slope you're right it's the it's the
biggest maybe
is it one of queen's does it still go on
can we parade
i remember it like my whole life because
it would come down prospect park west
and i grew up between eighth in the park
and we'd all run up and watch it the
bagpipe something about bagpipes
yeah makes you just want to kill english
people it's just what it is
you feel it in your body like something
about it shakes your bones
um and uh it was the first one you did
the the history short one the long story
short
it was so [ __ ] good but i remember i
was sitting in the front and like cherry
lane theater yeah i was i was hoping i
was like he knows who i i think he knows
who i am i think he's looking at me but
you probably won't it was it was [ __ ]
so good it was when you you it was like
on broadway or like
it was like that one i went and saw it
there live
and you saw it again when it was uh you
know on
was it on hbo after that yeah yeah but
that was the first of this new
thing that you started you like you
found that you were like this is you're
able to take
what what you guys are doing it's the
same thing history people act like
withdrawal history
we're talking about today it's history
it's the same thing right right
right well but eve but that's always
been colin saw if you watch his hbo
special
on the first one where he's wearing the
pirate's jacket and they have a mullet
and he's got a
the kid was a skinny kid skinny kid he
could have got punched through it yeah
it's good it was a good looking kid
it's a little thing called cocaine um
and so it's not cocaine no i'm kidding
i'm just kidding so so so it's like uh
so
but even his style that was the one
where he sat on the stage and got off
yeah and it wasn't history yeah
but it was that style is unique to colin
yeah you know what i mean
no but that wasn't my name tries to do
it now it's not funny
what's that no i said nanette hannah
gatsby tried to do it
i love how everyone just calls her
nanette yeah it's like
yeah she's the next one that's going to
write a review a positive review about
it too by the way she'll never be
supported by hannah gatsby because the
truth is i could just say quoted by
hannah gatsby and put a picture of
giannis face and it looks like enough
like hannah gatsby
were your what's your favorite ones my
favorite are i love them all but my
favorite is new york story
me too and uh and and the the first long
story short yeah
i love the way it ends in the car yeah
it's like you know yeah
here's how favorite my new york story
one was to me that when i was in an
ambulance with a heart attack and i
thought i was dying i was losing breath
uh what do you call that respiratory
what do you call it cardiac arrest when
you when you start your breathing starts
getting lower and lower what's the
medical term um
dying shallow breath uh i think it was
like respiratory i don't know
i was i was literally like this i was
like at least i got new york story out
wow really yeah that's how much i love
new york because
the way we all grew i mean you know new
york what it meant
and to be able to say hey guess what
this is not
crazy this is not racist oh shallow
breath this is how we grew up
yeah like that was so for some reason
that meant more to me than any of it you
know i mean yeah
so you really thought that when you were
laying there i thought about that and
here i am
we're celebrating we talk about park
soap we're celebrating this beautiful
new york vibe and chris is looking up
shopping
i can't handle it no no i can't
he's like i'm the medical guy he looked
to me for the answer and i didn't have
it yeah i'm gonna get it yeah you're
gonna get it off google which i could
have done yeah he could have done it no
but you just celebrated with us
no child check the tape i said dysphenia
nobody listening you guys were talking
about and then i just had to fact check
it and i was right
yes i want to check this out
mike you heard me say despina before i
busted out the phone they were too busy
talking about [ __ ] college heart
attack
to realize what a true genius i am it
could have been a perfect wrap-up
for all of us for loving new york yeah
and instead it's about despini that's
going to be the rapture yeah
the kid i mean he was talking about like
the thoughts about his the special he
shot yeah
he's on his deathbed and you're going
like you're [ __ ] i'm on [ __ ]
dating apps you're
googling cuz that's not [ __ ] yeah
yeah
yeah ah yeah he's on webmd
yeah so let's get so colin is he's in
the ambulance he's dying and he thinks
the new york story i think new york show
because i was like
the the beauty of like you during the
magic and just that everything was
you know intertwined in that way and
it's gone now
it's just this thing where there's so
many rules and regulations to what's
appropriate and it just
yeah it's dead and i knew it last year
my friend was
he he does mold inspections so he's out
in bedford stuyvesant i get a call from
his phone
and it's a lady in east new york
actually east new york brownsville east
new york
lady calls me up black lady it's like
hey um
did you this phone i see this number on
the phone
some guy left his phone and i'm like oh
that's my friend you're right
and she goes yeah i mean is he is
is he a white guy i'm sorry but there
was a white guy here earlier
and i was like this lady from
brownsville going i'm sorry
is he a white guy i was like it's over
yeah
if she's worried about being politically
correct doing somebody a favor you gotta
find their phone
in brownsville it's over is there any
good part do you think there's any
positivity to it you think it's like the
world's a better place or people trying
to be good
it's all bad well i mean i don't see the
good part i mean you know
i think that uh i think it's just phony
[ __ ]
well it's just kind of there's something
about it that's just when you're not
able to describe certain things it's
fake you know what i mean right yeah
it's just there's something about it
this just rubs my gut
my gut instinct is that it's wrong you
know yeah yeah thank you guys for
watching don't forget to subscribe
also turn on alerts more to come tell
from
absolutely and go to
patreon.comridgeboys to join the
matriarch or where things get
really wild